[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà la meilleure buteuse de l'équipe
de france de la dernière coupe du monde
avec quatre buts
wendy renard a devancé les attaquantes
c'est l'une des qualités qui fait d'elle
une joueuse hors du commun
hier la martiniquaise a été élu meilleur
défenseur du monde par la fifa
c'est la quatrième fois qu'elle remporte
ce titre à 29 ans sa soif de victoires
est intacte tiens compétitrices donc un
état d'esprit il est clair qu'on soit en
club ou en sélection je fais le maximum
pour à chaque fois aller le plus loin
possible dans toutes les compétitions
continentales
si l'équipe de france a chuté en quarts
de finale avec son club l'olympique
lyonnais wendy a une nouvelle fois tout
gagné la saison dernière championnat
ligue des champions
au total la native de schoelcher à six
ligues des champions et 13 titres de
championne de france à son actif dans
sept joueuses de l'eshop prix chopin
n'oublie pas d'où elle vient
je suis fier d'être martinique et je le
dis souvent je sais je sais d'où je
viens et je sais le parcours que j'ai dû
que j'ai dû faire pour en arriver ici
donc pour moi la martinique et c'est ma
ville c'est mon pays c'est c'est
c'est tout pour moi pour se motiver
avant un match et garder sa sérénité
wendy a un petit secret moi je suis
plutôt musicale antillaise surtout dans
les moments là les moments comme ça on
se rapproche un peu plus de ses racines
et et voilà c'est ça qui me permet
d'être moi-même et de rentrer sur le
terrain
et peut-être de faire tout le bas de
donner le maximum chorale pour l'équipe
avec 106 buts en club et 25 en sélection
wendy renard combien tout donné cette
saison pour étoffer son palmarès déjà
exceptionnel
mais son objectif principal sera d'être
un rempart en défense pour partir à la
conquête d'un titre avec l'équipe de
france
[Applaudissements]